today i'm going to talk about a topic
that some viewers have been asking me
about in a kind of tangential way and i
i get students occasionally
concerned about this and that's
originality which
is kind of an ambiguous idea or concept
or term it can mean a lot of different
things
and i think some of the
views that we have about originality can
end up being traps for us things that we
want to avoid and i can say that from my
own experience both as a
student on the one hand and then later
on as a researcher and author and
professor
so
i got to thinking about this first
because
i've had viewers from time to time ask
me things like
um you know it's great that you're
posting things about aristotle or kant
or nietzsche or or plato but when are
you actually going to post your own
original
work on on youtube
and
i don't
i don't see things in the way that that
question
kind of presupposes
you might say that that question and i
are like you know two ships not just
passing in the night but going off on
different different tangents
when do i actually provide my own
original thoughts on things if i do it
all i suppose it's in these kinds of
videos where i'm i'm you know
talking about more personal things
but i don't have a systematic philosophy
worked out of my own and i don't
actually
see a need to have something like that
and i'll talk a little bit about why
that that is in in a bit
what i'd like to say is that i've come
to think about originality after a lot
of time and after a lot of
trouble and anxiety and and striving on
my own part through through years really
as as a student and as a professor i've
come to think about originality in
different ways than i originally did if
that you know i'm allowed to make a pun
like that on original
i think that one of the things that's
important to distinguish right off the
bat
is
originality
for
students
and originality for practitioners in in
a field and if we're talking about
literature
maybe the bar is a little bit higher
because
there's always the possibility of
creating something that that seems to be
novel
maybe with philosophy it's a little bit
lower
maybe with history
you know in a certain respect it's even
lower because are you going to come up
with your own new
radically
different way of reading history no but
i mean you'll look at different new
topics new
new content
and maybe in other areas that the bar is
even even lower
i think the bar has to be far lower for
students than it ought to be for
anybody who wants to make claims to
originality as a practitioner in a field
when you're studying a field
there's this tendency especially in the
humanities the liberal arts for students
to and i understand this very well
because i got caught up in it myself for
students to kind of think that they have
to
come up with something new or else what
they're doing is is valueless
and you know let's let's distinguish
from the start you know
unoriginality in the sense of just
merely copying what somebody else is
doing
you know mechanically without actually
putting anything of your own
mind or thought or understanding with it
without grappling with it you know the
kind of stuff that people do when they
cut and paste from spark notes or
wikipedia or even you know from the
internet encyclopedia philosophy or or
the stanford encyclopedia philosophy and
reputable peer-reviewed sources
if you're not actually wrapping your own
head around it
and digesting it and reflecting on it
and making it your own
then i guess you can say what you're
doing is totally unoriginal right but
then you're probably doing something
akin to plagiarizing which is just
presenting somebody else's
thoughts and work and articulation as as
your own
i want to leave that aside i'm not i'm
not so worried about that
there's a lot of students who
you know they're reading plato for the
first time or reading aristotle for the
first time or even for the second or you
know even the fifth time you know if
they're an undergrad philosophy
major or even in graduate school you
know for the
for a lot of it
and they feel like they have to have
they got to say something new about it
or else what they're saying doesn't have
any
any value any merit because somebody
else has already done that and i want to
say to them
that's a very
particularly modern way of looking at
things
and the very people who you're studying
if you're studying ancient and medieval
and even certain early modern thinkers
they didn't see the practice of
philosophy or the practice of education
and the learning that goes on with it
and the the the work upon yourself the
work in taking the material and you know
bringing it into your own purview they
didn't see it that way
as a matter of fact there was a lot of
sort of
copying and regurgitating answers in the
beginning stages
so that you would have a basis
that you could you could work with
and you were expected to move beyond
that you know and fairly quickly
but not to radically leap beyond it in
the sense of leaving all that behind
you were supposed to
integrate that you were supposed to
assimilate that
and then if you managed to go a little
bit further well that's that's great
but
i mean here's something to think about
as a student
getting your head around what it is that
plato is actually saying that's no mean
feat and there's different layers and
levels of the text so at first you you
know you're working at the the sort of
superficial level and you say i've got
it i know exactly what he's saying with
this you know uh
analogy between the city and the soul
and
that's good that's that's an achievement
you've gotten your head around something
and you've got you know sort of concepts
that you can work with you're further
along than you were when you cracked
open that book
and if you can start applying that to
your own soul
you may not be necessarily right about
it but but at least you're you're doing
something intellectually stimulating and
if you come to the conclusion that this
is all bs and this is wrong that's
progress too but then you keep reading
it some more and some more and some more
and so other questions pop up for you
and you start saying there's more going
on here i think and you know what's how
does this connect up with this other
text over here
and this other scholar that i read he he
or she had a different view on this and
i i want to take that in and and see if
there's any merit to it
now you're getting into deeper levels
and the more and more that you do that
a lot of what you're doing is not
is not original in the sense that nobody
else has ever done it but it's original
in the sense that you haven't done it
it's new to you
and
that
progress that process that work that
effort that you're making to
understand something that you didn't
understand before or to make a little
bit more you know to go the next step
in understanding things to bring in a
few more things into the constellation
of concepts that you're working with
that really is valuable that is
worthwhile that is what it is to be
involved in perennial philosophy
it's not like there's perennial
philosophy there's a whole bunch of
truths out there that
exist independent of us and they're just
sort of waiting like you know fruit to
be plucked on a tree and now you got
them and you put them in your bag and
get all these nice propositions
i mean there are you know truths out
there that that are you know independent
of us
but you make them your own by bringing
them to yourself and working on them and
working on yourself and gradually
assimilating your mind to those those
you know truths or however you want to
see them these insights these uh these
great concepts and ideas
and so you know i think at the student
level
if you're doing that sort of thing
that's great
and to worry about trying to come up
with some radically different
take on things you know what a lot of
people think that's originality
after you've been teaching for a while
and you've seen you know generation
after generation of really bright
students grapple with aristotle and now
they're going to tell you how aristotle
got this wrong and you realize yeah i've
heard this before
this guy said that before and this guy
said this before and this guy said this
before
and and you know some of them were
scholars and said it in more irides ways
and the rest of them were students who
had this this problem grappling with
aristotle's text a lot of the ways in
which we're going to like go beyond
people and be original turn out to not
be original at all somebody's already
done that sort of thing
and
after a while these these leaps start to
become kind of predictable the more that
you do it
so that's that's all i'm going to say
about student stuff um
when it comes to being a practitioner of
of philosophy being somebody
for whom philosophy is not just a means
of you know earning some money or some
content that i happen to teach
but a way of
living and thinking and trying to sort
of you know bring things together
i was very concerned
with originality
at other points in my career i'm much
less concerned with that now
um
well why why is that the case maybe if i
tell you that it might help out some
some people along the line who
are in that kind of
that kind of trap or cul-de-sac or
circling around that
so
what do we mean when we when we're
talking about originality in terms of
like contributing to the the field like
doing something new
um
do we mean doing something that nobody
else has ever done
coming up with something that
nobody else has ever come up with
saying something nobody else has ever
said
that's one understanding of originality
um i don't think you get a lot of
mileage out of that
and i'll say why in in a little bit
or do i mean something like you know
something that's authentically
my own something that's like coming out
of who i am
and my experiences and my point of view
um
i i was very attracted to that sort of
notion of originality as as well and
those two can kind of go together
you know
maybe if your point of view is bringing
something new to the table you're
actually contributing some new
philosophical perspective or insight
and you know when i thought about this
sort of stuff i i worried about what is
my contribution going to be
to philosophy
is it going to be another you know
another
set of secondary works on pick whoever
on hegel on aristotle on derrida
am i going to um
start some group am i going to start a
journal i actually did start a journal
at one point that failed miserably
because i didn't know what i was really
doing um
what am i going to leave behind
you know and you think about this this
originality idea
sort of like
there's the person and then there's the
product and the value of the person lies
in the product maybe my originality
would be in like influencing a bunch of
new philosophers so that i would be the
you know
the uh
the schopenhauer to a great nietzsche
out there shoping however i consider to
be kind of
second grade which is good in philosophy
of nature i consider it first first
grade in philosophy
um
is that is that what i'm going to aim at
is that what i'm shooting for
um
what's the meaning of my my own life and
work and writing and my thought going to
be i worried about these sorts of things
what sort of changes am i going to make
to the world you know ever since mark's
kind of raised the stakes by saying
philosophy up until this point has been
um content to understand the world a
goal now has to be to actually change it
well you know what sort of change am i
am i going to make or bring
now a lot of people worry about that
sort of stuff and i worried about that
quite a bit especially as a an
undergraduate as a graduate student and
i would say even after grad school a bit
although
working in the prison was good for
humbling me
in that respect
while i was bothered by these these sort
of concerns
i
brought them up to my classics professor
with whom i i was studying greek and and
who i spent a semester reading plato's
symposium in in greek with rick williams
and
he wasn't a philosopher but he was you
know a guy who was really into plato um
he was he was a classist by
discipline and
training
but he understood this sort of dynamic
and so here's what he said to me he said
all i can tell you is this
my job is just to keep a fire going
and i said what do you mean by that i
said well
i came in
when there was a fire that was going for
a very long time
and other people had tended it and you
know put some logs into it from time to
time and kept it from going out and
people came and warmed themselves by
that fire and some of the people who
came warm themselves and they moved on
to somewhere else others came and they
they loved that fire so much and they
saw value it and they thought it had to
be
be
preserved and fed and kept in play and
so they they stayed and they
they
kept the fire going and i'm one of those
people
and it doesn't matter to me
whether anybody comes after me
of all the people who warm themselves at
this fire whether any of them stick
around if the fire dies out after me
then the fire dies out after me i did my
job i did what i needed to do i kept
this fire going
and i thought about that
and it didn't really make sense to me at
first and it took a while for me to
really understand that
part of what i was understanding is that
you know if we're really doing
philosophy the philosophy is more
important than the philosopher
even when we're talking about you know
doing say platonic philosophy or
studying nietzsche or you know
working our way through hegel it's not
the personality
or the individual
that's the locus of value and
what we really find worthwhile there
augustine was right about this
in pointing out that when it comes to
truth
or ideas or you know things of those
natures
we can all share in them we can all
participate in them together and there's
a way in which they're not really
anybody's possession so you know after
hagel wrote his phenomenology the
phenomenology in a certain way ceased to
be his own
and became a kind of common possession
that anybody who really wanted to work
their butt off could could dig into and
work their way through and see if there
was some truth in it or not
um
likewise augustine writing you know on
the
on the freedom of the will
it's you know by saying augustine and it
helps to know something about the guy
but
it doesn't really matter in some respect
that it's by saying augustine it's it's
the work itself
and and the quality that's there
so what about a different model of
of originality of looking at this sort
of stuff if there's problems with the
like i'm going to make some radical new
contribution it's going to be my
contribution that sort of sort of
view on that
um you know another different model i i
would say the best representative of
that is the book of ecclesiastes
um
you know nothing is new under the sun
everything that's been done has been
done before everything that's said has
been said before and it's not just um
you know the preacher quality who comes
up with this this has been said it many
times during during history and it's
kind of a pessimistic way of viewing
things
you can see pindar saying something
cattle like this in one of his poems
where he talks about
a human being he says you know
what what is a person what is not a
person aneers
man is but or a human being is but the
the
the the shadow of a dream
um
so we're like you know three steps
removed from
from reality and then it goes on but
when the god-given light comes
grasp it sees it and
so it's not a totally pessimistic
viewpoint but you know it sees
originality as like something that's
really not even to be concerned with at
all and and everything is just sort of
repetitious until something breaks in
and then when it does
which you can't predict just grab hold
of it and see where it goes
um
i i don't know if that if that is a very
useful way of looking at originality
either so i'm going to talk about a
third way here's here's how i see it now
i think of philosophy as a conversation
a big conversation think of like a giant
room with a lot of different people
talking to each other some of them don't
like each other some of them
misunderstand each other some of them
never actually come into contact some of
them are in intimate conversation with
each other for centuries
there's all different permutations and
possibilities there and we're involved
in that too and we come in and we
arrive late on the scene and we get to
hear these conversations taking place
and it takes us a while to figure out
what what are these people talking about
first of all and then you know do i want
to be over here over there or maybe over
there who do i want to listen to
and then after a while usually some of
us you know who are kind of
bold and stupid start you know
interjecting into the conversation right
away and make asses of ourselves um but
you know after a while we start to
figure out how to make better better
interjections
um so if you have this view of
philosophy as something like a
conversation and a practice and a way of
of
rationally reflecting on one's life as
part of the way one one lives one's life
then philosophy is not just something to
be
solved
or settled the way that somebody like
kant seemed to see it you know kant
complained a lot
that you know in metaphysics and in this
and this nobody had really made any
progress nobody had ever like come up
with the one single thing that everybody
would find convincing
and you know every time that i've read
that
even when i was an undergrad i thought
boy that's a misguided way of looking at
things
you know you can never get everybody on
the same page anyway
but
nobody made any progress and you'd be
like man did he read aristotle did he
read plato and yeah he did read
aristotle and plato actually taught
about them
did he really read them
did he
or did he kind of shoehorn them into his
own system his own way of being original
philosophy is also not just something to
kind of turn to account to make into
something useful and i would say you
know who are some people that you could
you could identify with that how about
bacon
you know
and uh the pragmatists in certain ways
and um
you know who else would fit in even marx
to a certain degree
canon fits in there although marx was
somebody who genuinely loved philosophy
and loved reading other people
i don't think philosophy it is something
useful it is something that contributes
a lot
in all sorts of unforeseen ways
but i don't think that it's that's the
whole purpose of philosophy
philosophy is something that affords us
a view
a perspective
and a capacity for ongoing
transformation i would say
and that i think is where the
originality
actually ought to be located
and where it would come in
so the realization that that
i had and i don't know exactly when it
took place so i suspect it was something
kind of gradual something growing on me
over
over time is that the great philosophers
the people
who
not only do we recognize them in the
canon is great but we also find
ourselves if we really have a love for
philosophy there's certain philosophers
that we can't shake certain philosophers
that we have to keep going back to like
rick williams you know he had been
reading he told me i've been reading
plato's symposium for 30 years and i
keep on rereading it and i said why
and he said because i keep on finding
new questions new things i want to
understand new things i want to know
about in this this great work
well that's that's the way and it wasn't
like that for aristotle for him that's
the way aristotle is for me that's the
way plato is for me that's the way
descartes is for me that's the way
nietzsche is for me that's the way a lot
of these people i keep coming back to
over and over and over again
um
you know i i can't keep myself away from
them
because there's still a lot of
things i want to know and understand and
every time that i invest the time and
work to do that
i find more and more that i hadn't seen
the time before and you know new
connections suggest themselves and open
themselves up to me
and
what's going on there in terms of
originality well i'm coming up with
things that are certainly new for me
and are any of them like you know
original perspectives on aristotle i i
don't know i don't know if i'm making
any
new contributions that would be up to
somebody else to to decide you know um
but anyway these guys articulated these
great thoughts
and these are these thoughts are partly
in their works
and they're partly sort of just
suggested in their works
so
with guys like aristotle or anselm i do
what a lot of what i call philosophical
detective work and i'll talk about that
some other time because that's like a
whole different conversation
basically what i'm doing is i'm i'm
trying to trace out certain concepts
that are puzzling me or interesting me
or fascinating me that i'm seeing over
here here here here here here here and
you know with this concept that i'm
saying here here here and then like
trying to correlate them and see how
they come together like what i'm doing
with aristotle and anger for example or
trying to put together saint anselm's
moral theory as a whole you know those
sorts of things
now is that is that making any sort of
original contribution
to me that is that that's as good as
originality as i want to get for myself
because i find that so incredibly
rewarding
and i love engaging with these these
guys i also find the the classroom
teaching that i do
helping you know students
understand what's going on in
aristotle you know coming up with new
examples
having the back and forth with students
seeing the aha moments
to me
if that doesn't involve originality for
me that's better than originality
there's something more valuable there
um
so you know i guess the question would
be
is do i do i have any originality am i
am i shooting for it
and i would say
maybe i i have to sort of
if i'm worried about originality the
notion of originality that i'm looking
for is something that kind of ripens
something that that you know
involves reflection occurring in
practical contexts over time
something a bit more sticky than our our
you know sort of clean contoured
conception
of originality that we often have that i
think is really just just a an
imagination and as such kind of a trap
for our desire
and leading us astray
i think that original work if it's done
takes an awful lot of
what would be from that vantage point
unoriginal
contributions that have to be all
brought together and assimilated and i
think
the product for me is less the thing
that's original then the process of
assimilation
and integration
and
everybody can do that whether they write
a
a book on philosophy whether they teach
philosophy
everybody has the capacity to to
experience that kind of originality
something that i would say is is more
genuinely at the heart of of a person
than some some product that other people
you know something that's externalized
and other people say oh yeah that's so
great let's put this in you know a
review of this in in the journal
and make sure that we put a blurb about
it on a you know facebook page and this
and that and this which turns out to be
not you know
you know something slightly new but not
anything
truly lasting what's really lasting is
the work that you do on your own soul
by studying philosophy so i'm going to
leave off
there with that thought the
real work of philosophy is working on on
your own soul